[Music]
hey you know the big story in New York
City continues to be Occupy Wall Street
protests that it's a huge story and all
week I've wanted to visit the protesters
myself I just haven't had time so
instead we sent a trustworthy
correspondent on to Occupy Wall Street
to give us an incisive an in-depth look
at what's been going on I'm talking
about our old friend triumph
occupy wallstreet here at yeast
infection Park on the corner of hurts
when I pee Boulevard we are out here
with a group of people who are
protesting our country's history of
allowing corporate greed to go
unpunished and as you can see from the
crowd many here are also protesting our
country's long history of proper hygiene
this protest is historic with many
important issues at stake and yet the
mainstream media will make sure that the
only coverage you'll see is this guy I'm
going to show you this guy and make fun
of him right to his face we need to wake
up to our abuse of the planet in pursuit
of corporate interests correct
thank you I'm with you man and I loved
you in the scary movies by the way you
know I wear the same mask when I go down
and joy behar this is an important thing
and I want you to have your say
so go ahead what's your cause besides
wanting more mms and trail mix look at
these kids you guys are married where
did you register at Burning Man we've
got the drum circle here and this is
very exciting I'm talking to Gabriel
from the drum circle
what would the protest be without the
drum circles besides bearable
I want to show you a few other options
that you might consider to a drum circle
in case you don't want to annoy people
for example during the Arab Spring in
Tunisia they did a saxophone the
rectangle during the civil rights
marches in the 60s they employed a piano
parallelogram and then this was in Kent
State the triangle triangle here's how
you can be useful to me okay
I need you to help me with my jokes
would you help me tell me sir what is
your cause besides protesting the high
price of Scooby Snacks that's cool
really takes the edge off in summary the
government is hiding the cures for
cancer since when the 1940s and he has
about 50 different cases that he wrote a
book on okay and he cured it way my diet
keep fighting the good fight I'm sure
your parents must be very proud
that your other siblings aren't here
with you what happens if the police come
in here it's going to be a serious
bloodbath or even worse for you
a regular bath
it's it because you might have to deal
with this the pepper spray stuff okay
now I want to demonstrate the secret is
not to blink okay check it out see
nothing nothing Wow anybody here ever
deal with pepper spray before yeah whose
can't please you kidding me
I like you've never dealt with pepper
spray that's how every one of these
dates ends is over this is perfect he is
in deep contemplative state he won't
have any idea that I'm pooping on him
here's one thing you won't be occupying
anytime soon a vagina
there's no penetrating him he is entered
into his own unique j.crew brand of Zen
I have a question
he's up he woke up he's woken up thank
God now can you give me directions to
Pinkberry I'm reporting here on Wall
Street now birthplace of the American
economy and home to more than 90% of the
people who bought the movie boiler room
on DVD and here with Bluetooth Magee
extraordinaire York I'm kidding I'm not
here to poop all over you
that's what you pay your Russian hookers
to do everybody knows that you know all
you need is your own protest science
Wi-Fi and limos now about this make a
porch that doesn't use Pirelli tires and
my other sign is a yeah I just have a
few quests
that is a coupon can't get these Wall
Street guys to talk to me wait I think
I've got an idea there we go
these protesters with their whining and
crying right don't they realize that
their public education are being funded
by the taxes you evaded each year I
don't want to keep you you're a good man
you know you better hurry back from
lunch so that you can collect your hurry
back from lunch bonus we are the 99%
thing we even understand it at all yeah
what is the 99%
besides the percentage of your diet
dedicated to caramel excuse me Fox News
can you tell me why the bull is
barricaded why the public has no access
to the food
please I just need access to his
testicles
please I'm around Olivera just one sniff
ok now I'm looking for our stockbrokers
we are a couple stockbroker we're all
over the 99% on the way here in 99% so
you don't have a lot of regard for tea
99% senior vice president you guys are
the good guys
you're creating jobs yes sure most of
the jobs end with you ejaculating on a
massage table
ladies and gentlemen exit question how
do you sleep at night I'm not talking
about your conscience and just with all
that cocaine in your system how do you
you know you're a good man let me take a
picture with you okay like this yes whoo
Oh giving that up in the sky that punk
well yeah yeah
hey ho hi yo - chance to pitch at have
got to go no justice no peace
Chaz Bono is obese
alright see now we got something 1% has
got to pay 1% lassie was an awesome name
they are throwing letters in the form of
paper airplanes at Citibank here in
terms of effectiveness I would put this
rally somewhere in between the civil
rights march and Team Coco get it up get
it up it's going to be good it's just
going ahead field now it's almost up now
we've got the pro days
[Music]
oh [ __ ] for me oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh yeah
oh yes enjoy your stay oh yes
make sure you see Mamma Mia oh yes oh
yes oh yes
[Music]
[Applause]
okay